[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Bilder sind grauenhaft und sprechen
für sich angesichts der peinlichen
Rückschläge auf dem Schlachtfeld besteht
eine der jüngsten Strategie in Russlands
in der Ukraine darin die
Zivilbevölkerung anzugreifen um sie am
Rande des strengten Grenchen Winters
ohne Licht und Wärme zurückzulassen ein
Winter in den die Temperaturen im
Durchschnitt zwischen -5 und plus zwei
Grad liegen es kann aber auch zeitweise
mal -20° kalt werden zum Zeitpunkt der
Aufnahme dieses Videos waren 40% der
gesamten stromerzeugungsinfrastruktur
der Ukraine zerstört und lauter
ukrainischen Regierung selbst wird es
wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer werden
selenski russland hat 40% der
Energieinfrastruktur der Ukraine
beschädigt die Ukraine waren vor
weiteren Angriffen auf die Infrastruktur
während der Bürgermeister Kiews dazu
auffordert sich auf das Schlimmste
vorzubereiten während des Herbstes haben
putinstruppen ihre wenigen verbliebenen
Raketen und präzisionsbomben zusammen
mit den iranischen Kamikaze Drohnen
eingesetzt umgezielt Wasser und
Wärmekraftwerke und die elektrische
Infrastruktur zu zerstören und das ist
durchaus ein Schlüsselfaktor in einem
Land in dem die Heizung der meisten
Menschen die in städtischen Gebieten
leben von der Wärme abhängt sie in
diesen Anlagen zentral erzeugt wird mit
anderen Worten wir reden nicht nur über
die Stromversorgung sondern auch über
die Heizung selbst
denn in der Ukraine sind die meisten
Menschen wie in so vielen anderen
Ländern auch von Fernwärme abhängig
Wärme und Warmwasser werden in großen
Kraftwerken erzeugt und dann durch Rohre
an die Haushalte verteilt und das
Ergebnis der russischen Angriffe ist
dass die Hauptstadt Kiel und viele
andere ukrainische Städte unter starke
Energie Rationierung Leiden das bedeutet
weniger heizstunden die
Straßenbeleuchtung wird nicht oder nur
minimal eingeschaltet und viele
Geschäfte können nicht oder nur
sporadisch betrieben werden abgesehen
von der Kälte und den Schwierigkeiten
die Menschen mit grundlegenden
Tätigkeiten haben müssen wir natürlich
auch den Schaden für die wirtschaftliche
Aktivität berücksichtigen
mit dem Ende des Herbstes und dem Einzug
des Winters hat sich der Krieg in der
Ukraine zu einem Zermürbungskrieg gegen
die Zivilbevölkerung entwickelt in die
russische Armee scheint davon überzeugt
zu sein dass sie auf dem Schlachtfeld
keine reelle Chance mehr auf einen Sieg
hat was wir also sehen ist der Einsatz
des Wetters als Kriegswaffe durch die
Russen so einfach ist das putin will die
Kälte nutzen um Wellen der
Unzufriedenheit oder Kriegsmüdigkeit
unter den Ukrainern zu schüren denn
einer der wenigen Möglichkeiten die dem
kann mir noch bleiben um wenigstens zu
versuchen sich aus diesem Konflikt ohne
totalen Gesichtsverlust zurückzuziehen
besteht darin dass die Ukraine selbst
sagen das ist genug ist und ihren
Präsidenten selenski zu verhandeln das
scheint eindeutig die Strategie des
russischen Diktators zu sein
fakt ist aufgrund der Bombardierung ist
die Versorgungslage mit Wasser Wärme und
Strom für mehrere Millionen Menschen in
der Ukraine äußerst kritisch die
Temperaturen in den meisten Teilen des
Landes liegen bereits unter dem
Gefrierpunkt und Russland verfügt nach
wie vor über Produktionskapazitäten für
Raketen die ist ermöglichen das rasante
Tempo der Bombardierung noch ein paar
Wochen beizubehalten doch jenseits
dieser Pläne Moskau könnte die Realität
hinterher ganz anders aussehen
denn so überraschend ist auch klingen
Markt in Wahrheit besteht die
realistische Möglichkeit dass sich der
ukrainische Winter für die russischen
Truppen als wahrer Albtraum erweisen
könnte und die Ukraine auch weiteres
Bombe eindämmen könnte so sehr die
Ukraine auch gezwungen sind in der Kälte
und Inhalt dunkel zu leben die Russen
könnten am Ende die Hauptlast tragen und
ihr fragt euch jetzt bestimmt warum
eigentlich war der Winter nicht
historisch gesehen meist eine Vorteil
für die Russen auf welche Weise genau
können Kälte Schnee und extreme
Bedingungen das Schlachtfeld wirklich
beeinflussen welche der beiden Seiten
wird davon am meisten profitieren oder
geschädigt werden am Ende dieses Videos
werde die all das und noch viel mehr
genau verstehen aber zuerst ist es erst
einmal Zeit für ein wenig Geschichte
[Musik]
general Winter kennt keine Gnade
okay historisch gesehen ist der Winter
einer der großen Verbündeten des
russischen Bären
wie er sicher bist oder Napoleon Armee
im Winter 1812 in Russland besiegt und
Elektron 380.000 von Verluste sowohl
durch Kämpfe selbst als auch durch
Hunger Unterkühlung und Krankheiten und
etwas mehr als ein Jahrhundert später
verdammte ein Bekannter Diktator während
des Zweiten Weltkriegs innerhalb 1941
seine Truppen zu einem noch schlimmeren
Debakel Hitler machte im Grunde die
gleichen Fehler wie Napoleon als er sich
in die Arme des russischen winterstürzte
ohne dass seine Armee an die Bedingungen
gewöhnt oder entsprechend vorbereitet
gewesen wäre das brauchte wer macht am
Ende das Genick und Millionen Menschen
kamen dabei ums Leben
aber das ist natürlich nicht die ganze
Geschichte denn im Laufe seiner Historie
hat auch Russland schlechte Erfahrungen
mit der kalten Jahreszeit gemacht zum
Beispiel mussten 1939 während des
winterkriegs gegen Finnland davon
absehen ganz Finland anzugreifen nachdem
sie zwischen 130 und 160.000 Soldaten
verloren hat über finnlandsrolle in
diesem Winter werden wir euch nachher
noch einiges erzählen aber damals bekam
die Sowjets immerhin einen
Friedensvertrag der Ihnen einige
finnische Gebiete zu Sprache
obwohl der Winter also normalerweise ein
Verbündeter Russland ist könnten sie in
der Ukraine ähnlich enden wie in
Finnland 1939 oder sogar noch schlimmer
noch schlimmer in die verlorene Schlacht
um Kiel der Zusammenbruch der russischen
fronleichnamen Offensive sind nicht im
Winter passiert sondern im Frühjahr im
Sommer und den Herbst in diesen Monaten
war das Wetter natürlich kein derart
relevanter Faktor das russische
Donnerstag wurde vor allem durch die
technologisch Überlegenheit und die
Nachrichten dienstlichen Informationen
die Ukraine von ihrem westlichen
Verbündeten zur Verfügung gestellt
worden er hat beigeführt zusätzlich zu
enormen Hartnäckigkeit und den
außergewöhnlichen operationellen und
taktischen Fähigkeiten der Ukraine
selbst und aufgepasst in diese Vorteile
könnte der Winter noch verstärken
tatsache ist dass die Wintersaison die
Dinge für die Hosen noch viel schlimmer
machen könnte obwohl es natürlich auch
für die Ukraine kein Kinderspiel sein
wird eine Krieg immer russischen oder
ukrainischen Winter ist für niemanden
der springende Punkt ist jedoch den
Ukraine war dies schon immer klar
weswegen sie sich entsprechend gerüstet
haben und ausgerüstet wurden während die
Russen noch lange von ihren je gegen
Spaziergang nach Kiew trocken eine
fatale Fehleinschätzung die mit jener
der hochmütigen Perser vor der Schlacht
bei den thermophylen im Jahr 480 vor
Christus vergleichbar ist zumal auch der
Ausgang ähnlich war aber kommen wir nun
wieder in die Gegenwart zurück bzw je
nach Frage welche auch die Zukunft
entscheiden könnte warum räumen wir den
Winter so viel Bedeutung ein wie könnte
diese kalte Jahreszeit den Verlauf des
Krieges beeinflussen schauen wir uns das
doch mal ganz genau an
der Winter verzeiht keine Schwäche
im Gegensatz zu den Beispielen mit
Napoleon und Hitler sind es heute ja
nicht die Russen die unter der Invasion
fremder möchte leiden sondern sie selbst
sind die invasur das hat viele
Auswirkungen die sich gegen sie richten
könnten und das weiß auch der kleine mit
dem Ende des Sommers oder Ankunft des
Herbstes haben sie versucht den Druck
durch Angriffe auf zivile Ziele zu
erhöhen aber damit ihr genau versteht
warum der ukrainische Winter zu einem
Albtraum für Putin die weitere Strategie
des Gremmel und die russischen Truppen
werden könnte werden wir euch vier
Hauptgründe nennen und ja der erste
Punkt hat viel mit dem Einsatzgebiete
selbst zu tun oder besser gesagt mit den
Kämpfen außerhalb Russlands wir sprechen
hier natürlich über die Versorgung der
Truppen obwohl sich der Krieg auf die
Grenzgebiete konzentriert die Russland
der theoretisch am besten versorgen kann
bestätigen Wahrheit nun mal daraus dass
so eine Mission im Winter gar nicht so
einfach ist der Grund dafür ist das ein
großer Teil der Front insbesondere die
Regierung weit von den russischen
Versorgungs und Produktionszentren
entfernt ist obwohl sie so nah an der
Krimi liebt denn auch acht Jahre nach
der Annexion wird die Krim immer noch
hauptsächlich von Russland aus sofort
und mit den grundlegenden Gütern
beliefern es stimmt zwar das andere
Konfliktgebiete wie das Gebiet donjewsk
gute Verbindung zu Rostock am Don haben
einer großen russischen Industriestadt
mit mehr als einer Millionen Einwohnern
aber der Rest der Front hat nicht so
viel Glück
[Musik]
in jedem Fall ist es keine leichte
Aufgabe schweres Gerät und große
Ladungen aller Art über von der
gefürchteten Betroffenen Böden und
Straßen zu transportiert ja die für die
dortigen Landschaften und unbefestigten
Straßen typische schlammzeit hat eine
eigene Bezeichnung was auf Deutsch
wirklich übersetzt weglosigkeit bedeutet
sie verhindert für gut einen Monat
jegliche Truppenbewegungen und gleich
nach der Rast kommt der strenge general
Winter mit extremen Minustemperaturen
und dieser sogenannte general Winter
setzt nicht nur den Truppen psychisch
wie physisch stark zu sondern macht auch
Waffen und Fahrzeuge und brauchbar und
behindert nach schubwege durch große
Schneemassen und ist der General Winter
erstmal überstanden kommt dann mit der
Schneeschmelze auch noch die nächste
rastiza während dieser ganzen Zeit wird
Russland also noch mehr auf den
Schienenverkehr angewiesen sein also
sonst das Problem ist dass die Eisenbahn
abgesehen davon dass ich viel
unflexibler ist einfach nicht überall
hinkommt außerdem ist sie viel
anfälliger als der Transporte über
Straßen wenn es dem Ukraine gelingt sie
durch Angriffe und Sabotage ab schneiden
dann könnten sich die massiven
logistikprobleme die die Russen bereits
bei der Versorgung ihrer Armee haben
noch vervielfachen und natürlich kann
ein Mangel an Nachschub gerade im Winter
entscheidend sein
im Gegensatz dazu spielen die Ukraine
auf heimischen Boden was aus
logistischer Sicht einen großen Vorteil
darstellt aber das ist noch nicht alles
um im Winter überhaupt kämpfen zu können
braucht es zwei Dinge gute Vorbereitung
und die richtige Ausrüstung
es gibt nur wenige Herausforderungen die
schwieriger sind als der Kampf bei
Minusgraden und der Umgang mit Knie
tiefen Wasser und Schlamm in die
Schützengräben Schnee Eis und Frost und
hierbei könnten die Ukraine die Oberhand
haben nun ja ich denke die meisten von
euch kennen die Geschichte bereits laut
westlichen Geheimnis Informationen sind
die mobilisierten Truppen Russland
schlecht ausgebildet und haben keine
geeignete Ausrüstung für den Krieg
Russland Soldaten sprechen es offen aus
wir wurden ohne jede Unterstützung an
die Front geworfen die enorme Zahl der
Elite Verluste die im westlichen Quellen
beispielsweise auf 80 bis 100.000 Tote
und Verwundete geschätzt wird hat die
wussten dazu veranlasst zwangsrekruten
einzusetzen
das heißt neue Soldaten die auf
Hochtouren mobilisiert wurden und in
vielen Fällen praktisch keine Ausbildung
erhalten haben bevor sie an die Front
geschickt wurden und selbst die die mehr
Glück hatten haben kaum eine geeignete
Vorbereitung erhalten ja man könnte
meinen dass die Ukraine mit einer sehr
ähnlichen Situation konfrontiert sind es
gibt jedoch einige wichtige Unterschiede
erstens es ist nicht dasselbe bei einem
Heimspiel also treten und in den eigenen
Städten zu kämpfen als dies in einem
fremden Land zu tun ohne das Terrain zu
kennen ohne die Unterstützung der
Bevölkerung zu haben und mit einer
unterirdischen Moral zweitens kann die
Ukraine mittlerweile mehr professionelle
und Kampf erfahrene Soldaten auf dem
Schlachtfeld aufbringen als Russland in
dieser Hinsicht waren die territorialen
Verteidigungskräfte ein voller Erfolg
wir haben darüber in einem eigenen Video
berichtet und drittens erhalten viele
ukrainische Soldaten und Beruf Soldaten
oder territorialstreitkräfte mit erster
Kampf Erfahrung seit Anfang des Jahres
eine erstklassige Ausbildung die dritten
z.bilden seit Monaten ukrainische
Truppen aus und jetzt haben auch viele
andere europäische Länder damit begonnen
17 Oktober 2022 EU-Länder stimm zu
ukrainische Soldaten im Rahmen einer
neuen Mission auszubilden theoretisch
scheint die Ukraine also auch einen
Vorteil gegenüber den Russen zu haben
wenn es ums Know-how geht und das ist
etwas was im Winter verdammt viel wert
ist
der dritte wichtige Grund hat mit der
Ausrüstung zu tun die den Soldaten zur
Verfügung steht seit Beginn der
russischen Invasion der Ukraine ist eine
der Tatsachen die am meisten
Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat dass viele
russische Soldaten nicht über moderne
individuelle Ausrüstung verfügen bereits
Ende März also nach nur einem Monat
Krieg litten über 10% der russischen
Soldaten an so schweren Erfrierungen
dass sie kämpfen tauglich waren das
papierendste ist jedoch dass ihre
Führung daraus überhaupt keine Lehren
gezogen zu haben scheint im Laufe der
Monate hat sich dieses Problem nur noch
schlimmer die russische Armee hat neu
eingezogenes Soldaten absolut keine
Ausrüstung gegeben und die Familien
gezwungen Schutzwesten und Kleidung zu
kaufen damit die Wehrpflichtigen eine
Chance haben zurückzukommen niemand weiß
wirklich was alles und wie viel noch in
den Poster russischen Armee vorhanden
ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal großen
selbst fakt ist jedoch dass es ihr nach
neun Monaten Krieg an allem fehlt
Raketen modernen Panzern Munition und ja
auch individuelle Ausrüstung
[Musik]
der Kampf unter extrem kalten eisigen
und verschneiten Bedingungen erfordert
eine besondere Ausrüstung die Stiefel
der Soldaten müssen zum Beispiel
niedrigen Temperaturen standhalten und
auf Eislaufen können und die Kleidung
muss thermisch und gleichzeitig leicht
sein damit der Soldat sich frei bewegen
kann angesichts der klimatischen
Bedingungen in Russland sollte man
meinen dass die russische Armee mit all
diesen Dingen gut versorgt ist aber
tatsächlich deutet alles darauf hin dass
das genau Gegenteil der Fall ist die
Berichte die uns von der Front erreichen
zeigen dass die neuen russischen
Soldaten oft mit praktisch leeren hinten
ankommt
das Problem der russischen
Versorgungslage liegt natürlich auch
darin begründet dass man schon zu
Kriegsbeginn zu schlecht vorbereitet und
vieles nur auf den Papier vorhanden war
während die Lager selbst durch korrupte
Führungskräfte geplündert worden oder
der Verrottung überlassen worden waren
etwas wovon ein isolierter Herrscher im
Kreml aus dem geschulten berichten seine
Hand verließen ja sagertruppe eben
nichts mitbekommt Korruption unländisch
auch eine gewaltige Bremse wenn es darum
geht auf die Schnelle eine
leistungsfähige Produktion für einen
derart riesigen Bedarf zu organisieren
mit dem man die defizierte einholen
können um 300.000 Winteruniformen
herzustellen benötigt man jedoch ganz
andere Strukturen als sie die russische
Staatswirtschaft aufbieten kann wir
haben über dieses Problem bereits vor
Monaten in einem eigenen Video berichtet
in der Zwischenzeit haben die Ukraine
von ihrem westlichen Verbündeten schon
seit Monaten tonnenweise winterfeste
Ausrüstung für ihre Soldaten erhalten
allein Kanada liefert 400.000
Winteruniformen und auch Deutschland
steht ein imposantes Winterpaket für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zusammen es
ist also sehr wahrscheinlich dass die
Tiere Armee bereits gut ausgerüstet ist
jedenfalls viel besser als ihr Gegner
die Natur schafft eilig Ausrüstung in
die Ukraine während Truppen sich für den
Winter verschanzen westliche Länder
beschleunigen die Lieferung von
Winterkleidung neuen
Artilleriegeschützen und
drohnenabwehrsystemen nach Kiew während
sich die ukrainischen und russischen
Streitkräfte auf einen monatelanges
schuften im Schlamm und Eis vorbereiten
und wisst ihr was genau das gleiche gilt
für schweres militärisches Gerät
[Musik]
wenn in der Ukraine die ersten
Schneefälle einsetzen Schichten sie sich
übereinander auf und werden zu hartem
Eis das fast bis zum Eintreffen des
Frühlings bleibt und nach dem Eis kommt
mit dem Frühjahr wie gesagt der Schlamm
der am Ende noch schlimmer sein kann all
das führt dazu dass beide Armeen bei
ihren Vorstößen viel eher die Straßen
benutzen die normalerweise saubere
gehalten werden oder zumindest leichter
zu reinigen sind anstatt zu versuchen
Querfeld ein oder auch unbefestigten
Landstraßen die Fortbewegung dort kann
zu einer wahren Hülle werden ich weiß
nicht ob ihr euch daran erinnert im
ersten Monate Invasion als es in der
Ukraine noch Schnee und Eis gab immer
auf den Hauptstraßen verrückten und das
war einer der Gründe warum ihre langen
konvers sehr verwundbar waren habt ihr
noch die russischen Lastwagen und
gepanzerten Fahrzeuge vor Augen die
stecken geblieben sind weil ihre alten
Reifen geplatzt sind erinnert ihr euch
noch an die ukrainischen Hinterhalte auf
die konvoice die damit endeten dass die
Russen ohne Mengen an Gerät und Material
verloren und das alles könnte sich
wiederholen wenn die Russen wieder
versuchen sollten auf dieselbe Weise
vorzubringen und vergesslich das all
dies im Februar und März als die Russen
noch deutlich mehr Ressourcen zur
Verfügung hatten und im Vergleich mit
dem ukrainischen Truppen noch günstiger
da standen stellt euch also vor wie
fatal dies jetzt für sie ausfallen würde
man könnte meinen dass ich in diesem
Winter etwas ähnliches wiederholen
könnte etwas ähnliches aber definitiv
nicht dasselbe denn auch die Invasoren
haben dazu gelernt
[Musik]
die Russen wissen nur zu gut dass ihre
alten modische Panzer und Lastwagen im
Winter nicht gut im Gelände
zurechtkommen also werden wir
wahrscheinlich weniger Kämpfe in der
freien Natur sehen bereits im Laufe der
letzten Monate haben sie weitgehend
damit aufgehört mit taktischen
bataillierungsgruppen zu operieren da
sich ihr Konzept als extrem fehlerhaft
herausgestellt hat dabei wurde gerade
dieses Konzept als der wichtigste
Fortschritt im Rahmen der umfassenden
Modernisierung der russischen
Streitkräfte in den letzten zehn bis 15
Jahren gesehen er bedeutet eine Abkehr
von veralteten sowjetischen Modell der
Großverbände aus Region und die Vision
mit 10.000 von Männern hin zum
flexibleren westlichen System der
amerikaden aus dynamischen taktischen
Formationen nun hat sich aber endgültig
herausgestellt dass dieser vitale
Bestandteil in Putins und Rassismus
Modernisierungsprogramm täglich
gescheitert ist wir haben über dieses
übrigens bereits lange vor der Invasion
ein umfassendes Video gedreht dass ich
euch verlinken werde der Hauptgrund für
das Scheitern liegt unsere Ansicht nach
darin dass die Struktur und zwar
organisatorisch und materiell
umgestaltet worden eine grundlegende
Form von Natur und Mentalität der
Streitkräfte sowie der Gesellschaft auch
sehr sicher rekrutieren sträflich
vernachlässigt wurde diese sind jedoch
eine unerlässliche Grundlage für das
Funktionieren des Gesamtkonzeptes
flexible Gruppierungen stellen nun mal
hohe Anforderungen an die Qualität der
Führungskader und verbindungsoffiziere
die eine gute Zusammenarbeit der
einzelnen bataillierungsgruppen und
deren logistische Unterstützung
gewährleisten und der britische
Geheimdienst hat weitere taktische
Gründe für das Scheitern identifiziert
in den hochintensiven groß angelegten
kämpfen des ukrainekrieges haben sich
mehrere Schwachstellen des taktischen
Bataillons kampfgruppenkonzeptes gezeigt
die relativ geringe Anzahl Ankunft in
den bataonen hat sich oft als
unzureichend erwiesen die dezentrale
Verteilung der Artillerie hat ist
Russland nicht ermöglicht seinen Vorteil
in Bezug auf die Anzahl der Geschütze
voll auszuschöpfen und nur wenige
Kommandeure waren in der Lage
Gelegenheiten so flexibel zu nutzen wie
ist das Modell eigentlich vorsah dass
ich ein zentrale Bestandteil der neuen
russischen Militär als ungeeignet
herausgestellt hat ist dabei kein
Kindheit stellt einen gewaltigen Körper
für die Russen da eine Militär ist ein
komplettes in sich schlüssiges System
von Prinzipien welche alle möglichen
Situationen und die Arten die sich
daraus ergebenden militärische Aktion
und Reaktionen festlegen und glaubt mir
eine Militär Doktrin ist keine rein
akademische Angelegenheit nein in ihr
stecken jahrzehntelange Erfahrung und
Planung und auf ihr Fuß der gesamte
Aufbau des Militärs eine Armee lässt
sich nicht einfach so planlos aus dem
Boden stampfen oder über Nacht
umkrempeln man muss sich aus einer
unendlichen Zahl an Strategien und
Taktiken für die optimalen entscheiden
und die Struktur Ausrüstung und
Ausbildung unter Streitkräfte müssen
dann über Jahre so geformt und aufgebaut
werden dass sie den aus dieser Auswahl
Erwachsenen Aufgaben und
Herausforderungen gewachsen sind die
Militär doch drin ist also die Grundlage
die Blaupause und Handlungsanweisung der
gesamten Streit macht die Tatsache dass
ein großer Teil ihrer Doktrin nun
Makulatur ist und nicht so schnell
ersetzt werden kann lässt die Russen
taktisch mit blanken Hintern da stehen
und fähig in diesen Krieg noch
nennenswerte Initiative übernehmen zu
können
[Musik]
die widrigen Wetterbedingungen im Winter
stellen aber auch für andere
Kampfsysteme ein großes Problem dar
Regen Schneefall Stürme und Nebel
behindern zum Beispiel in Einsatz von
Drohnen die für beide Seiten notwendig
sind um Ziele zu bestimmen und
Präzisionswaffen einzusetzen aus diesem
Grund ist eine der Möglichkeiten für den
Winter in Betracht gezogen werden dass
der Krieg obwohl er nicht wirklich
aufhört in eine Art schlummerphase
Eintritt in der die Operationen die wir
sehen einen viel kleineren Umfang haben
und Entwicklungen die langsamer
verlaufen gleichzeitig wird die
Ausrüstung aber durch die rauen
Wetterbedingungen und die komplizierten
Bewegungen durch das Gelände viel
stärker in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
und wisst ihr was das alles ist alles
andere als im Sinne der Russen ein
längerer Krieg erfordert kontinuierliche
nachschubbemühungen und durch die
zusätzlichen Verschleiß der Ausrüstung
könnten die Russen noch viel mehr
Probleme bekommen das liegt vor allem
daran dass die Ukraine über modernere
schwere Waffen verfügt und auch sonst
ihr Ausrüstung meist in einem besseren
Zustand ist
beispielsweise wurden viele der T-72
Panzer die die Ukraine heute einsetzt
Anfang des Jahres von Polen gespendet
und nach ihrer Überholung mit
einwandfreien Zustand geliefert das
gleiche gilt für andere Panzer und
Waffen Ausländer wie Tschechien und das
Slowakei und nicht nur das die
ukrainischen Verbündeten in der Regionen
nicht Slowakei und Tschechien warten und
reparieren die ukrainische
Militärausrüstung pünktlich und
Modernisieren sie sogar wir sprechen
hier von einer komplexen Prozesskette
aus Wartung gut Updates von Waffen im
Handumdrehen entstanden ist und die ist
in Ukraine ermöglicht den großen wieder
ein paar Schritte voraus zu sein gut nun
könnte man meinen dass die Russen sich
wenn sie keine echten großen offensiven
mehr durchführen könnten einfach ein
Graben müssen um ihre Stellung zu halten
aber auch das wird für sie alles andere
als gemütlich denn wirklich übel wird
der Winter vor allem für zwei
kriegswichtige defensivelemente die
Infanterie und die Logistik
lass mich das kurz erklären im Winter
geht viel Deckung verloren weil die
Bäume und Büsche keine Lauf mehr tragen
das bedeutet dass man sich ständig
niedrig am Boden halten muss und Gott
ist es verdammt nass schlammig und vor
allem kalt Nässe und Kälte führen jedoch
zu einer extremen Verkürzung der
möglichen Aufenthaltsdauer von
Infanteristen in ihren Stellungen man
braucht in einer solchen Umgebung viel
persönliche Disziplin um sich überhaupt
regelmäßig trocknen und Aufwärmen zu
können
jeder einzelne Soldat für sich muss
äußerst gründlich seine Masse und seine
trockene Ausrüstung getrennt halten und
sich genau überlegen wie er unter diesen
Extrembedingungen seinen Ort wechseln
kann seine Mobilität wird also stark
eingeschränkt denn wenn seine trockene
Ausrüstung nass wird ist in kürzester
Zeit kampfunfähig und muss sich schnell
an einen warmen und trockenen Ort
begeben an diesem Ort muss es aber Strom
oder Feuer geben und beides ist
unterfeldbedingungen äußerst selten nun
sind die Ukraine sowohl hierbei als auch
bei den Faktoren persönliche Disziplin
und fällt Erfahrung den Russen vor allem
den frisch mobilisierten haushoch
überlegen denn sie haben sich ja Jahre
lang durch den Winter hindurch
verteidigen müssen das ukrainische
Militär hat auch eine vernünftige
nachwuchsführung und die Leute passen
aufeinander viel besser auf bei den
großen hingegen sehen wir immer wieder
dass sie sich nur auf einen Prinzip
verlassen können jeder ist sich selbst
der Nächste wenn man sich die
ukrainischen Kampfstellungen ansieht
sind sie in der Regel gut gepflegt die
Soldaten waren angezogen und die
Verteidigungslinien haben oft Bereiche
die sauber trocken und warm gehalten
werden zudem haben die ukrainische
Streitkräfte wo die beste Unterstützung
bei der Ausbildung die sich für den
Winterkrieg vorstellen kann
Finnland bietet an ukrainische Soldaten
für den Winterkrieg gegen Russland
auszubilden Finnlands Präsident salini
install hat erklärt dass ein Land den
ukrainischen Streitkräften die
Ausbildung geben kann die Sie brauchen
um gegen die russische Aggression
vorzugehen ja genau ausgerechnet die
Filme mit Erschrecken der Roten Armee im
Winter Krieg und wohl auch der Albtraum
des russischen führungsnachwuchses der
mit keinerlei Unterstützung durch solche
Profis rechnen kann und der Graz ist ja
jetzt schon extrem hoch die neuen
mobilisierten Soldaten haben wieder die
Erfahrung noch die Fähigkeiten um über
einen längeren Zeitraum Umfeld zu
operieren sie haben größtenteils keine
Winterkleidung erhalten und ihre
Kampfpositionen sind oft ein heilloses
Durcheinander diese Achillesferse werden
die Ukraine zu nutzen wissen und dafür
sorgen dass die Russen durch die weitere
massive Verluste erleiden aufgrund ihrer
verringerten manufrierfähigkeit werden
die russischen Verbände außerdem stärker
auf zentrale Knotenpunkte angewiesen
sein an denen sich Soldaten erholen
können diese Knotenpunkte wird die
Ukraine als mittlerweile besser
ausgerüstete initiativ macht
konzentriert greifen und die Moral der
Russen weiter zermürgen sie kann Ihnen
also allein dadurch hohe Verluste
hinzufügen indem Sie sie in ihren
Kampfpositionen hält und ihre Angriffe
dann so zeitlich koordiniert dass eine
Rotation der russischen Einheiten
verhindert wird das Ergebnis wird eine
hohe Sterblichkeitsrate durch
Unterkühlung und Krankheiten sein
[Musik]
was die Logistik angeht so sind die
meisten militärischen
unterstützungsfahrzeuge auf Rädern
unterwegs und beide Seiten sind für den
Nachschub sogar stark von zivilen
Transportfahrzeugen abhängig und während
der [ __ ] Panzer und andere
Kettenfahrzeuge oft noch einen
Hersteller das Problem darstellt
bedeutet er für Logistik Fahrzeug auf
Rädern den Tod außerdem schenkt er die
Anzahl der Achsen ein auf denen sich
danach schon bewegen kann und ein
langsamerer Nachschub verringert
zwangsläufig das Tempo der Operationen
die schlimmste Folge des Winters für
Panzer und Schützenpanzer ist also nicht
dass sie nicht mehr meine frieren können
das ist länger dauert sie zu versorgen
oder reparieren und zu Becken wenn sie
ihn Schwierigkeiten geraten das
verringert die Fähigkeit von Durchbrüche
auszunutzen und macht offensiv Aktionen
ungemein C und postspielig für das
ukrainische Militär das versucht nach
den jüngsten offensiven wieder
Kampfkraft aufzubauen sollte das Ziel in
diesem Winter daher darin bestehen die
Russen mit Artillerie Scharmützel und
konstanten Druck auf Distanz zu halten
und zwar auf immer größere Distanz
die Ukraine ist bereit für den ersten
Einsatz eine 150 km präzisionsbombe in
die Ukraine steht kurz davor der erste
Nutzer der bodengestützten Bombe mit
kleinem Durchmesser LG lsdb von Boeing
zu werden die Ziele in einer Entfernung
von bis zu 150 km treffen kann berichten
zufolge erwecken die USA die
Langstrecken präzisionsbombe nach Kiew
zu schicken und russische offensiven
abzuwehren die GLS die die würde es in
ukrainischen Truppen ermöglichen weit
hinter den russischen Linien
zuzuschlagen und so die Möglichkeit
eines Gegenangriff zu verringern dies
entspricht genau der Strategie des
Pentagons der ukrainische schrittweise
immer mächtigere Waffen zur Verfügung zu
stellen so dass die russische Moral ist
Disziplin und Kampfkraft Scheibchen weiß
es nicht werden ohne eine endgültige
abstreckung herbeizuführen auf diese
Weise werden die russischen Verluste
maximiert und der Kreml ist gezwungen
diese zu ersetzen damit ihre Freund
nicht kollabiert das bedeutet wiederum
das mehr frisch mobilisierte Soldaten
mit schlechtere Ausbildung eingesetzt
werden eine Städte Abwärtsspirale für
die Russen wäre die Ukraine weiter
bewegt wird die Initiative zu behalten
dies dürfte auch an der russischen
Heimat von für große Probleme Sorgen
denn die kreml-propagandisten haben es
immer schwerer die wiederholten
Rückschläge immer wieder ansehnlich zu
verpacken es ist nun mal offensichtlich
dass ihr Feldzug alles andere als gut
verläuft das Versprechen einer gezielten
chirurgischen Operation ist genauso im
Sande verlaufen wie die dem Moment dies
eine allgemeine Mobilisierung jetzt 9
Monate später ist den Russen klar
geworden das es sich um einen Konflikt
mit hoher Intensität handelt und die
russische Öffentlichkeit ist eine
Gefangene der eigenen krasse
widersprüchlichen Mentalität geworden
denn es wäre ein großer Fehler die
russische Gesellschaft zu idealisieren
Putins Verhalten beruht auf einer
breiten gesellschaftlichen Forderung
nach nationalistisch imperialer Größe
diejenigen die damit ein großes Problem
hatten haben bereits versucht Russland
zu verlassen der kritische Teil der
russischen Gesellschaft ist verkümmert
und schwach und es gibt keine Anzeichen
dafür dass einen größeren Einfluss haben
wird andererseits ist jedoch die
persönliche Opfer Bereitschaft selbst
der Kriegs auf ihn Bevölkerungsteile
stark begrenzt ihr Motto wasch mich
Putin aber macht mich nass vor allem
nicht an der Front eine breite mobil
machen
nicht nur logistisch und materiell
sondern auch propagandistisch eine
extrem große Herausforderung für den
Travel im Winter wird es daher eher
weniger so groß angelegten
Offensivaktionen kommen es sei denn es
kommt irgendwo zu einem Zusammenbruch
der Verteidigungsstellung das bedeutet
aber nicht dass die Kämpfe oder der
Munitionsverbrauch zurückgehen und was
den Russen mit ihrer begrenzten
Produktion Logistik weiteres kurz
zerbrechen bereiten durfte natürlich
können wir nicht wissen was genau
passieren wird aber alles deutet darauf
hin dass der Winter dieses Mal nicht den
Interessen des Krems gibt und vielleicht
ist genau das der Grund warum wir
gesehen haben und weiterhin sehen die
Russland neues Spiel in diesem Krieg
darin besteht Ukraine einfach alle mal
an den verhandlungsrecht zu bringen in
diesem Zusammenhang machen die
Androhungen des Einsatzes von Atomwaffen
über die wir sehr Politik sprechen
werden und die Angriffe auf die zivile
Infrastruktur die beim Anfang des Videos
gesehen haben sehr viel Sinn aus diesem
Grund spuckt der Gremmel auch Schleim
und Galle wenn es um die mögliche
Stationierung von Patrick Luft
Abwehrsystemen in der Ukraine geht
Russland die NATO vor der Lieferung von
Patrick System
vor der Ukraine Patrick
Raketenabwehrsysteme zu liefern und
bezeichnet das Bündnis als kriminelles
Gebilde das Waffen einer extremistische
Regime Lieferer die Ukraine hat ihre
westlichen Partner um Luftabwehrsysteme
gebeten darunter auch patrius Systeme
aus den USA um sie vor russischen
Angriffen auf ihre Energieinfrastruktur
zu schützen ist eben wie immer ein
verlässlicher Indikator dafür wo vor der
Kreml wirklich Angst hat denn die
Patrick Systeme sind wesentlich
leistungsfähiger als die
bereitstationierten Iris t-systemen eine
entsprechende Entscheidung Washington
könnte also die letzte Hoffnung Moskau
in offen gegen die ukrainische
zielbevölkerung zunichte machen alles
deutet darauf hin dass man sich im
Grunde durchaus bewusst ist dass dieser
Winter nicht zu jedem Verbündeten wird
den man sich erhofft hatte von so einem
knallharten und unbarmherzigen Feind
keine einzige Rechnung Putins ist
aufgegangen und die Unterstützung des
bestens für die Ukraine aufzuhalten er
hat es weder geschaffen doch die
Europäer im Winter frieren zu lassen und
er wird auch die Ukraine dadurch nicht
in die Knie zwingt aber jetzt seid ihr
anderer Reihe glaubt ihr das Russland
einen Kriegswinter besser überstehen
wird als erwartet meint ihr die Ukrainer
sollten sich dem russischen Terrors
sozial und militärisch widersetzen und
die energieerpressung abwehren oder
sollten Sie Offenheit für Verhandlungen
mit Putin signalisieren wie immer sind
wir auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video etwas gebracht an ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
was ja gibt uns bitte ein Like heißt mit
euren Freunden und vergessliches Abo mit
Glöckchen und keines unserer Videos mehr
zu verpassen natürlich freuen uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video mach's gut bis bald
[Musik]